what's going on everybody today we got
the official logo for spider-man far
from home it looks a lot like the logo
from spider-man homecoming but that's to
be expected because it is a sequel as
you can see the text that says far from
home is the same font that was used for
the spider-man homecoming logo that says
homecoming and of course the O in the
home for each of the titles is
spider-man's logo slashed his face even
though our man Peter Parker is
technically dead right now I think we
all know that he will somehow be brought
back to life in Avengers 4 unless this
somehow takes place before the events of
infinity war and Avengers 4 but I doubt
it especially because it's released
after Avengers 4 comes out the resource
sticking to you the whole no one's
actually coming back to life sort of
deal but I think we all know that it's
going to happen the Russo brothers are
infamous for trolling pretty hard
especially during the events of infinity
war so I don't think that this is going
to be any different and another thing
why haven't they made an official
announcement that Jake Gyllenhaal will
be playing Mysterio we all know he is he
was recently spotted on set they're
really trying to keep things under wrap
and they're doing a good job at it
because we haven't even seen a
spider-man suit yet we don't know what
suit he's going to be wearing in far
from home because if we did and we saw
that he is wearing the iron spider suit
we would know that this takes place
after the events of Avengers and
infinity war and Avengers 4 and of
course they really don't want us to know
that spider-man along with all the other
heroes will be brought back to life at
some point in time in Avengers 4 but hey
official logo for spider-man far from
home getting closer we're getting more
information about it hopefully soon some
official photos will be released and
we'll have a little bit more information
let me know what you think about this
photo and let me know when you think
this movie will be taking place before
the events of infinity war in Avengers 4
or after hit me up in the comments and
you can
hit me up on any social media Instagram
Twitter Facebook I'm trying to use those
more as always I appreciate you liking
this video and if you're new to my
channel don't forget to hit that
subscribe button so you can stay up to
date with everything relating to
spider-man fire from home Marvel DC and
all things superhero thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]